who are you under there
i'm vengeance
since his debut in detective comics all
the way back in 1939 the character of
batman has appeared in 16 different
movies
from early costume tights to feature
length live action films batman has run
the whole spectrum of genres in both
live action and animation in his film
franchises batman has turned into lego
blocks been reduced to camp and firmly
grounded in reality the newest iteration
from filmmaker matt reeves is taking
audiences all the way back to his
detective roots so without further ado
and no spoilers here is everything you
need to know before you watch the batman
over the course of the various batman
related films audiences have mostly seen
one repeated introduction to the
character generally the murder of bruce
wayne's parents followed by scenes of a
young bruce trained to become the
legendary hero while juggling his dual
identity as a rich orphan playboy and
his caped crime fighting persona the
batman does not present a young wayne
but instead presents a young batman this
film is set during the second year of
bruce wayne's exploits as a vigilante
there is a serial killer on the loose
dubbed the riddler because he leaves
riddles at each crime scene once the
riddles begin to mention the batman
specifically gotham's lieutenant jim
gordon teams up with the anonymous
masked hero in an attempt to catch the
killer before the riddler can strike
again when the riddles begin to connect
batman to his tragic past this
particular case becomes more personal
for the caped crusader the batman is
also an origin story for selena kyle who
is on her own mission to learn the truth
about her past kyle of course is given
the name of the beloved character of
catwoman
in her attempt to find answers she'll
tango with the worst of gotham's
criminal underworld including mob boss
carmine falcone and falcone's right-hand
man the penguin when selena's search for
answers leads directly to the batman the
duo both loners with an eye on revenge
find solace in one another after
realizing that for the first time in
each of their lives they discovered
someone who truly understands their pain
and desperation but batman's
entanglements with both selena and
lieutenant gordon will also test his
fortitude on no guns and no killing
before getting into some of the comic
and film references for reeves let's
shine the bat signal on reeve's amazing
cast first robert pattinson takes on the
role of bruce wayne and slips into the
suit and cow of batman though most know
patton's in from his twilight films at
the start of his career it's not his
association with playing a sullen
vampire in the past that makes pattinson
a perfect choice
since starring in the popular y.a series
pattinson has remade himself by working
with some of the most exciting indie
directors like the safety brothers for
good time rubber eggers for the
lighthouse and james gray for the lost
city of z reeves has matched that combo
with his own filmography with the panic
struck monster movie cloverfield
followed by let me in the eerie remake
of the instant vampire classic let the
right one in and the final two films in
the griddly rebooted planet of the apes
trilogy dawn of the planet of the apes
and war for the planet of the apes
joining pattinson as the franchise
mainstays are jeffrey wright as
lieutenant jim gordon planet of the apes
andy circus as wayne's butler alfred
pennyworth and zoe kravitz as selena
kyle kravitz recently told us about her
character's pull toward batman i think
she really wants to be free from her
past i think in the story you know i
think she's trying to
liberate herself
from a lot of trauma and a lot of pain
and um you know the cat woman that we
know and love who's really able to
relish and enjoy the chaos she's not
quite there yet i think she really
is struck by the connection she has with
batman because i think both of them are
people who never feel seen or connect to
anybody and i think it's a little scary
to meet someone who
affects you the way that we affect each
other other cast members include john
tuturo as carmine falcone and peter
sarsgaard plays district attorney gil
coulson the batman's villains take two
of the most outlandish 90s movie
villains and grounds them inside gotham
with more reality-based personas deep in
the criminal underworld and deep inside
a mountain of makeup is colin farrell as
the penguin farrell recently told us
about the duality of reeves grounded
vision and the fun he got to have under
the prosthetics the one thing matt
always wanted to be aware of with this
film and i think it's really really
clear when you see it as everything is
grounded everything is believable
everything is practically reachable
through your understanding as a human
being and physically as possible as well
um but the the makeup and the thing yeah
yeah yeah so that was fun paul dano will
play the riddler whose civilian identity
in the film edward nashton is one of his
known aliases in the pages of dc comics
dano's take on the riddler promises to
be far different from jim carrey's in
batman forever right from the get-go of
matt's script he had a really clear
point of view
of what he was bringing to this film
you could see the film as you read it
and
something that i was really
moved by
was
that he was exploring the two sides of
trauma maybe and you know the batman is
born of trauma right bruce wayne losing
his parents and i guess i was really
interested also in the mask and the idea
that
a vigilante in our world you know we can
see what we we often can see what we
want to see and
even though to a lot of people the
batman stands for good i can tell you
that i as my character
saw him representing exactly what i
wanted to as a as a great source of
inspiration and and power
the riddler serial killer is where
reeves was able to pull in the
influences that would return the batman
to his detective routes from 2020's
first trailer unveiling at dc fandom
through every bit of press now reeves
has emphasized repeatedly that batman is
not an origin film to start in batman's
second year reeves mined numerous
sources both within dc comics extensive
library but also some of the best
psychological thrillers and crime opuses
in film and television let's start with
dc reeves cites the long halloween by
jeff loeb and tim sale as a prominent
influence for the story set after the
events of frank miller's seminal batman
year one storyline the long halloween
sees batman attempting to learn the
identity of a serial killer this text
also accomplishes a few other things
like chronicling the continuing
deterioration of gotham's organized
crime families but the key to the long
halloween was batman encountering a
mystery he could not easily crack early
on reeves said he wanted to emphasize
batman as the world's greatest detective
an element of the character generally
downplayed in the more action-oriented
film cycles made by zack snyder and
christopher nolan while also playing up
the noirish elements inherent in the
concept at a recent q a reeves said from
long halloween i was thinking about the
calendar man and the different sort of
killings and then this idea came to me i
thought we could do a thing where at
these crimes there's correspondence left
for the batman so the idea that suddenly
someone is shining a light on him and
that would be very unsettling to him
reeves continued at the qa by saying i
thought about the zodiac killer and i
thought about how in this horrific way
the zodiac left all these ciphers and
these communications to the police and
to the newspaper and how unsettling that
was
and i thought wow that actually sounds
like a horrifying version of the riddler
because he leaves all these puzzles
while reeves has brought up zodiac fans
online have picked up on another david
fincher vibe for the riddler noticing a
similar visual palette to his earlier
fictional serial killer film seven but
this should not suggest that the batman
is a straight adaptation of the long
halloween as beyond subbing in the
riddler as the serial murderer someone
key to the story is missing from the
film harvey dent who would become
two-face
in lieu of harvey peter sarsgaard plays
the corrupt district attorney gil
coulson an original character for the
film jamie lawson also plays an original
character in the film bella rial who is
running for mayor and challenges bruce
wayne to do more good deeds for the
citizens of gotham yep it looks like
robert pattinson is in another franchise
with a fearless woman named bella
for pattinson however instead of the
long halloween reeve suggested that the
actor read darwin cook's ego which
details bruce wayne's grappling with
batman's moral code and whether he wants
to continue crime fighting pattinson
told us how he wrestled with that idea
what i got from ego
and from quite a few other comics is
he he believes it he when he believes
and he puts on the suit he disappears
and i thought it was interesting to kind
of think that
bruce feels
as himself
impotent to help anybody and
[Music]
and avenge his parents he needs to
completely embrace his alter ego and so
in our telling of the story like bruce
hasn't really got control of his persona
as bruce yet like he's just
he's a recluse that can he's a recluse
and he's not he's not the kind of
playboy that we've seen in other tongues
of the story like he's
he's a freak nevertheless the batman
takes the thematic ideas from the long
halloween and batman ego and leaves most
of their plots within its pages beyond
finchers zodiac and fincher's fbi series
mine hunter reeves has also cited the
award-winning detective dramas the
french connection in chinatown as
neo-noir influences on the batman but
let's not get too far removed from the
batman we know and love sure there's a
serial killer a cat burglar and gotham
politicians and gangsters but there's
also the batmobile forgetting the more
outlandish design conventions
established in batman 89 this car is in
fact a muscle car with some obvious
modifications long time readers of the
batman comics may even recognize the
broad strokes of the design as the one
batman used throughout most of the 1980s
and into the 90s
despite all the telltale markings of a
reboot the batman's place in the loose
continuity of dc film slate is still up
for debate during the early phase of
development reeves suggested it could
take place outside of continuity like
todd phillips's joker but quickly
backpedaled to say it will likely have
some ties to the known dc universe and
that there may even be a cameo or two
but then again the dc universe is a
place where world changing events can
create convenient retcons
there will be multiple previous batman
chiefly michael keaton and ben affleck
in the flash for example as for now this
specific batman is in his own specific
gotham what we do know is that pattinson
and reeves have discussed a trilogy
i've talked to matt about the idea of
doing a trilogy and uh
and that would be wonderful i mean i
really really enjoyed the process and
it's such a fun character to play and
yeah it'll be that'd be lovely the
batman will be released at the beginning
of a full 2022 roster for the dc film
universe which includes the flash
aquaman and the lost kingdom and black
adam we wouldn't put it past warner
brothers to try and eventually connect
them to the batman but we won't be
disappointed if they remain separate in
the meantime though the principal cast
is expected to return for at least two
sequels to the batman so strap in for
175 minutes and try to decipher all the
clues in the batman for where reeves and
perhaps dc might be going from march
through the rest of the year for today
now you know everything you need to know
before you watch the batman
[Music]
you